[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by rachel cruz bestselling
author and host of the rachel cruz show
and we are excited to take your calls
america so give us one triple eight
eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
we can talk about your life your money
what's going on in your world inflation
weddings kids cars houses and so much to
talk about all of it all of it i'm
overwhelmed just thinking about it
weddings and inflation two great topics
that's true and we are here for you
today to give you the right next step
for wherever you might find yourself so
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five eric is kicking
off this hour he's in harrisburg
pennsylvania eric welcome to the ramsay
show
hey thank you great to be on awesome how
can we help
hi so i'm a 20 year old college student
um
right now i'm working full full-time
um
basically my work pays for my
schooling and i have about seventy
thousand dollars in savings awesome um
so i've been dating my boyfriend for
about six months now okay and i was
wondering when the uh right time is to
bring up the finance question in a
relationship
finances and a relationship how long has
this relationship been going on
about six months okay so pretty early on
i mean i like to as you're heading
towards you know a more serious
commitment like a marriage i think you
can start talking about values now and
where you stand on
your views on debt and money i don't
think you need to go showing bank
accounts and be like well here's my
situation because we're not combining
any finances until marriage yeah that's
right yeah and i mean with anyone when
it comes to
relationships you know it's it's when it
when you know okay i'm going to be doing
life with this person getting married
and we have our future ahead right and
so when that happens that's when all
conversations get around it gets real
about every subject and then needs to
include money for sure and the problem
is
is that people go into these um go go
into relationships and then they take
the next step and
for whatever reason fear they don't
think it's that important whatever it is
they end up kind of
holding back and pushing back and then
once you're married and you're realizing
oh wow we have to actually do life
together that's when it gets complicated
yeah so are there fears right now eric
when it comes to finances and what the
takes are
um i would say yes the main reason being
is because um you know i know my
boyfriend has about maybe 30 000 in
student loan debt
um and our finances are
um very different so i just didn't want
the um relationship to be about um money
sure well i think the the key here is
how you know aggressive is he about
wanting to pay these student loans off
versus oh they've got student loan debt
so i can't be with a person who has debt
to me it's more about the mindset and
their values when it comes to money and
that's the stuff you can talk about now
but you don't need to be like well we
gotta you know we gotta make a plan
right now this is the time
no one on a first date is going you know
rachel i want to know how much debt you
have before we move forward in this date
show me show me your taxes
you know respect you don't want to be
disrespectful you don't want to come on
too strong here but i think talking
about values so like hey just curious
like what are your thoughts on on debt
how do you view money yes what did you
learn about money growing up for sure
because the truth is too that one of the
number one causes of fights and then
that lead to divorce
is money so i'm like if we know there's
a big thing out there that's an issue
it would be unwise
to
you know
it'd be unwise to to ignore it yeah
earlier we can nail down that hey we're
on the same page with money the better
yes so i like that but we don't need to
get into the weeds and the details until
there's more commitment in this
relationship so thanks so much for the
caller appreciate it let's move on to
connor he's in houston texas connor
welcome to the show
hey it's great to be on here absolutely
good to have you
what's going on so
my question is uh
similar actually i just got engaged last
week
and
thank you thank you and we're wanting to
know if we should
put money
or open like another savings account
like specifically a high yielding
savings account and just fill that with
money for uh the wedding well we should
just keep it
or yeah yes or we should keep it in our
own
you know
bank accounts and just throw cash in
there and you know and just use that so
that's our that's our question yeah it's
a great question i love the idea of
having a separate account for something
that's going to be
you're going to be using it a lot uh
it's something you're going to want to
stay on budget for
and so you want to know the exact number
of what you guys have when you have it
all of it and it's just easier to
separate it out you know getting a
savings account i mean or a check or
even a separate checking account because
you probably will be writing a lot of
checks or using the money obviously out
of it uh for vendors and that kind of
thing so to to continue to stay
uh up with what's going on what's being
paid out all of it i think it's great to
have a step one winston and i did that
actually that was our first and then we
and then we ended up going into that
account
my first checking account that's sweet
our first checking accounts yes wow
because we had our separate and then we
got home so you get married and we put
all the wedding budget stuff in that one
account and then after we got married i
was like well both our names are on it
so we're like we'll just transition all
of our stuff to combine into that
account well that was already existing
that's smart that makes sense yeah no it
wasn't my first checking account no no
no no no no i mean an hour like i just
met yes yes that's right that's right as
a couple so i like that idea just
because it keeps it separate from
everything else
yeah i'm a big fan of that and do you
guys have a budget right now that you're
saying hey we're this is the number
we're shooting for
yeah we we want to keep it somewhere
from like 10 to 15 000 15 000 being like
the most we'd want to spend but
so ideally 10 but 15 is the hey we're
not spending a dime more than this
ideally you'll probably spend 15 connor
just prepare yourself prepare your heart
we had a range too and well we were on
the
the other end of that round
but i like planning plan for 10. how
about that let's plan for 10. george
would say 10 i'd say you'll probably do
15. that's great either way conor you
got a plan you're using cash you guys
are it's gonna be great enjoy the
process yes you can get stressed out and
all of it don't let anyone pressure you
into making decisions about this wedding
that you don't feel comfortable making
you and your fiance
this is your day and so many people
rachel they put so much pressure on the
wedding day and they don't even think
about setting themselves up for marriage
yes they spend more time planning the
wedding than marriage and then they walk
into the marriage going oh my gosh what
what the crap happened actually connor
i'll give you the piece of advice i gave
my little brother when he got married
take that budget
split it in half and keep the other half
for marriage therapy later on so this
whole account you're like good when we
need
counseling when we need therapy did
daniel take that advice no he didn't no
he didn't it's a joke it's a fun time
for real though your marriage is a
lifetime the wedding's a day enjoy it i
hope it's wonderful i hope your fiance
feels beautiful and she loves it all of
it but
it's just the day so don't get too
caught up but y'all i think y'all are
gonna do great connor yeah you're the
fact he's thinking about this connor can
i give you a wedding gift
yeah absolutely sweet i'm going to give
you one year of ramsay plus
and i know it's i know it's not a lame
gift
i thought you were laughing genuinely
was like
wait what are you doing george that's
what i'm doing one year ramsay plus
kelly's gonna pick up and get you
connected with that plug into the every
dollar plus budgeting app we've got for
you connects to your bank account watch
all the financial peace university
videos it's like pre-marital counseling
it's great it's great go through it plug
into it you're gonna love it super
excited for you guys as you enter this
chapter of your life give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's talk about your
life and your money i'm george campbell
joined by rachel cruz today this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ramsay
personality rachel cruz
and we just took a call about weddings
and i want you all to stick around
because later this hour we are going to
be talking about this big wedding boom
we are seeing weddings back bigger than
ever before and we're going to share
with you some of the worst wedding
advice we have ever heard it's a big
claim but it might be it's up there
rachel we'll just we'll just hashtag
tick tock that's right
people hashtag still a thing i don't
think i don't use them do you
i don't know i don't know i'm not that
fancy we have social media professionals
here to help us i know but anyways it's
it's great so stick around for that
we're gonna be talking weddings it seems
to be a hot topic lately we're gonna get
into it all right let's go to the phones
this hour open phones triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call caitlyn joins us up next she's
in arizona caitlyn welcome to the show
hello how are ya good how can we help
today
yeah i just had a quick question in
regards to overcoming a negative mindset
so i'm 29 i live out in arizona i'm a
single mom and as you know our
housing market has been so intense to
say at least
um and i'm paying about 60 percent of my
take-home pay in rent wow i
yeah i can't buy in this market i don't
make enough i pulled down to about 40
last year um and i just feel like i'm
spinning my wheels and that treading
water feeling is really starting to get
to me so i was hoping you could provide
some insight on that as possible
yeah i mean i'll be honest caitlyn i'm
like i i would feel that too if if more
than half the paycheck is going to
housing that's a that's a big chunk so
tell me
um a little bit more about kind of the
situation because you are obviously in a
more expensive i don't know if it's an
area or apartment or what it is is there
other options for you to to change
locations just to at least
catch your breath and bring it down to
at least you know
we recommend 25 30 but even if it went
down to 35 that would change your world
right yeah i live in a two bedroom
apartment right now um and i pay about
2000 a month i had looked at going down
to a one bedroom the only trouble with
that it was it would only save me maybe
300 bucks a month but i actually work
from home um so i need and i have my son
here with me too so i don't know how we
would make that work yeah no two
bedrooms yeah yeah
yeah so have you read i haven't
i was going to just say have you have
you driven you know 20 miles
either direction of where you currently
are just to see other prices
uh right now i'm already kind of on the
edge of um
what i would consider to be a safe area
um so
i can look maybe a little bit deeper
into phoenix but i just want to make
sure
we're still safe and everything's good
like that so um i just i mean i work
remotely so i could probably buy in
other states and other markets but my
son's father's here and i really just
don't want to leave my home state so for
sure
and how much do you make a year
i pulled down about 40 last year okay
what are you doing for work
i work at a call center for an insurance
company okay
so there's there's only two ways we can
go about this and we can we can spend
less and we can make more so do you have
any payments in your life that we can
get rid of do you have any debt
i don't have any debt um i do have that
going for me i don't have any debt and i
do
anticipate my income going up i actually
i had a conversation yesterday with my
supervisor that made me feel like maybe
something close is on the horizon um for
getting my my pay up
i think it's just this waiting period
between
making more money and trying to find
something cheaper to rent it's just it's
mentally even draining me i think but
sure um
especially as a single mom i mean you're
you got your how old your held your son
he just turned six his name's mason i
think he might be listening that's
awesome
oh you're doing an incredible job
caitlyn i mean you know the the hard
thing is it's nothing that you're doing
wrong it's just that the numbers are
kind of stacked against you and so like
george said you know an option of
bringing in more i mean right now the
job market is just
insane and so i would push and look to
see if you can even i mean
40 grand you know you're you're you're
doing fine
but man people are paying just insane
amounts of money right now for jobs and
and since yours is not like very
specifically specialized you know what i
mean like i feel like you could um do
all sorts of things uh even with the
experience that you've had in this
insurance role
um so you know i don't know if it's
looking for something else or a
different apartment but one of those two
things really probably it needs to shift
for your own sanity katelyn you know
what i mean like
temporarily yeah to have the numbers
work for you um
it's going to be a big deal do you have
an emergency fund katelyn
i do yeah okay three to six months in
there
uh i still have my baby one
i have a 1 000 emergency fund and then i
have about 4 000 in my my actual
emergency fund so i still need to build
that up okay i think building that up
may help with a little bit of that
financial peace and anxiety about what
if something happens if one check
doesn't come in what are we gonna do and
if you get that in place then i'm gonna
start saving up for a house slowly and i
know it's hard because there's not a lot
of margin right now but that feels like
it's the long-term goal and i'm hoping
that all this craziness is not forever
and so a year from now hopefully we're
looking at a very different picture and
you are work from home and so that does
open you up but i know you've got to
still stay close to home because of the
situation with your son and so there's
not a ton of options here other than
let's look at the budget let's do a
budget audit where can we save every
single insurance premium every single
expense i'm going through that with a
fine-tooth comb going how can i shave
off 10 bucks 20 bucks 30 bucks yeah
absolutely and then the income i mean
the yeah income and apartment
um
situations would change too you know
yeah but you're doing a great job and
you really are you're doing a great job
for for where you're at incredible no
debt
you have savings i mean all of it you're
you really are but that sixty percent it
oh
that that hurts me it's a tough
situation and this inflation stuff i
mean it's hitting people all over their
pocketbooks from rent to gas to food and
so there's you just batting down the
hatches and let's get to work let's get
the second job if we have to let's trim
the subscriptions that we're not using
right now and all the little luxuries
that we once enjoyed might need to go
away temporarily yeah for a season
because they're saying you know
i read a report and they think in the
next 18 months with just even the
um
the supply chain all of that but i'm
like i mean the hard thing is after two
years i've just learned who knows like
who knows that's right i remember
april of 2020 doing instagram lives i
did one like every other day just to
answer questions and
i remember i said guys i think by august
i'll do this
it's all gonna be over
here we are so i'm not predicting
anything but
uh i think you just have to prepare with
where we're at the reality of what's
going on and what and what sucks is that
that means cutting back some because the
numbers everything is going up yeah and
if you're single you don't have kids
there's more options because we can go
all right let's get you a roommate now
it's more difficult when you have a
family when you've got your kids
involved it's not that simple right but
if you work from home that can open you
up to a lot of options too and you may
not want to live on the outskirts of
town but for temporarily for a year if
we have to sign that lease to go all
right we can now breathe and still hit
our other financial goals i'm okay with
that and it's amazing what peace of mind
even does right like we can talk about
the numbers and the percentages and all
of that all day long but there is just
something to be said
about when you do have margin it gives
you a level of peace like a level of
like you can take a breath
and sometimes it's worth
the things you never thought you would
do i never would live this far from
wherever right people make these claims
and then when life starts hitting you
and you think okay is it now i would
rather live far farther away
and actually have peace of mind and
margin and enjoy life a little bit more
than everything just getting sucked out
of the paycheck so much out of our
control too and so i always like to go
what is in my control yeah so in
caitlin's situation if i'm anyone
listening right now i'm going all right
let me make a list of ways i can make
more and ways i can spend less i'm gonna
make a list of five things and i'm gonna
go okay which one can i go do this week
this month and just start trying things
what can i sell on facebook marketplace
that's been sitting in the closet for a
while what is that second job i can take
for a few months to just supplement my
income temporarily yeah and so if you
start doing all that and that's why i
love the budget audit it's kind of a
real nerdy thing but you go man i'm way
overpaying for auto insurance let me
connect with xander and oh my gosh i
just saved a hundred bucks right there
and you start doing that in all areas
we've talked about this on your show
rachel with cable and internet and yeah
how can we start shaving all this down
our phone bills to where now we have 200
bucks a month yes and margin and you can
breathe a little bit yeah and it's not
easy i'm not trying to make it sound
like it no but it's the stuff that's the
kind of the auto the auto draft the auto
pay where you're just like oh and then
you look up two years you're like well
i've never
pushed on that or seen that you know
what i mean and doing that it does it
gives you gives you some more margin
yeah you got to advocate for yourself
and get yourself in a better financial
position and that's why our plan works
and good times and bad i mean imagine if
she had all these debt payments
yeah cool great work caitlin you've done
a great job good job this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me and thirty thousand dollars all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's bethel
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by my co-host
rachel cruz host of the rachel cruz show
you can check out all of those shows and
podcasts wherever you listen to podcasts
and on the ramsay network all right
rachel so we've been talking about
weddings and i've got this article here
from cnn weddings are booming again
they're bigger and more expensive than
ever we love to hear that
this year's wedding boom is projected to
be big according to a new report from
wedding planning site than not it
anticipates as many as 2.6 million
weddings taking place in 2022 the big
events will also be much bigger and
likely more expensive amid record levels
of consumer price inflation on average
couples spent a total of thirty four
thousand dollars on their wedding in
2021 including the ceremony reception
engagement and wedding rings than not
reports said this is getting crazy
i mean it's wild and i just know someone
i know people personally that yeah they
didn't they didn't have their wedding
because of kovid like they weren't able
to
have the wedding they wanted so they
waited actually we know someone that's
on our team and she's getting married
tonight that's right yeah i mean it's
just it is wild and it's and it's an
expensive
day
it's an expensive event
uh i always think about the friends
episode with chandler monica monica's
like if you call it a party one more
time because it's like our big party
she's like it's not a party so yes it's
an event it's a day it's a day yeah when
you divide the cost out by how many
people are attending and you go oh my
gosh is uncle richie really worth 214
dollars that's the problem like the per
head thing is when you start getting
declines you're like okay good thank you
that's a great feeling that people you
didn't really want to show up that your
parents made you invite i know so
hopefully they're not listening right
now sorry they won't even know who they
are hopefully
yeah
so here's the deal with all these
expensive weddings comes a lot of
wedding advice
and a lot of that advice happens to be
on the internet and a portion of that
internet is tick tock rachel and i know
you have some feelings about tick tock
but there's a specific video that i
wanted to show you i wanted to watch
together as a family and i wanted to get
your reaction are you okay with this i
can't wait okay here is some of the
worst wedding advice i've heard okay
let's go
so i wanted to share with you
the best wedding advice
of all time the second that you get
engaged
open a credit card
now i know you're going to say i already
have a credit card
get a new one get one that's running a
promotion but what you're going to do is
you're going to put every single wedding
expense you ever have on that card even
if the vendor charges like a two percent
credit card fee pay the fee it is worth
it seriously um we got a ton of bonus
points we put everything on that card
because we already have cash saved
and so i think a lot of people think
like well let's just pay with cash then
we're not in debt right but you already
have the cash so we just use it to pay
off the credit card every month
but we're still getting miles and that's
like where the money really is so then
when you have all these miles you use it
to literally book the honeymoon of your
dreams for free
okay oh there's so much there to unpack
rachel we could we could sit here all
day i know but it's the mindset that is
so it's a mindset that's a good point
that's so normal this is the normal
cultural most people listening and
watching go i don't get it what was
wrong with that that advice that's true
yep yeah use the points go on the free
vacation it's all work out all gonna
work out
even if you have the cash that'd be okay
that was the wildest part they've got
the cash to do it apparently and she
says even though you have the cash put
on the card
here's the thing
this and this is tried and true it's
always been true
because there's been study after study
after study that when you choose to
spend someone else's money
naturally you are going to spend more
because there is not an emotional
connection to the money you're spending
so as you're planning this wedding and
putting everything on the credit card
you're like well yeah yeah yeah let's do
that or the you know that dress the
dress it's like
800 more it'll be fine because we're
going to get the points we're going to
future right now they start you start to
justify
you really do these these transactions
and the expenses and
and doing a little bit more is actually
better i'd rather spend more because i'm
going to get the airline miles on the
back end so it's going to be fine
and the crazy thing is when you look
especially a wedding budget the average
wedding is 34 000
and you give yourself any leeway
emotionally to say oh we can we can
spend a little bit more
how much more thousands and thousands
and thousands that you're probably going
to spend again because there's just not
that i'm there's not a feeling of okay
that's my money leaving so you are
to get a plane ticket to cancun and i'm
like listen plain it's expensive right
now i get it sure
but but it's not thousands let's just
say a thousand let's say it's a let's
say it's 500 there 500 dollars okay two
people it's two thousand dollars i
guarantee you they spent more than two
thousand dollars because of the idea
okay well we're gonna we're gonna get
some on the back end oh yeah
anyway can i just go one more journal
please oh i know everyone's like uh and
this doesn't i don't feel this way this
is how i this is one of the reasons i
really just don't like i don't like the
whole industry of credit cards because
in order to get those miles in order to
get those points it's not because
mastercard is like this generous you
know
and they're like you know what you've
been just so great so i'm gonna just
give you
give you something
they have trillions of dollar like
billions billions i'm gonna say
trillions i don't know that's true but
billions we can say for sure
of dollars for people that don't pay
their credit cards off and are paying
interest so the people that are
mismanaging their money you get to go
get your
hundred dollar plane ticket paid for but
and i'm like it's gross that doesn't
feel good it does well to me i'm like
you know what the whole end gross can i
just use my money and like stay away
from like i don't even want to
participate i don't participate so i'm
not part of that system i don't like it
i don't like wow well we dug into this
on the fine print podcast that we did
and we interviewed an ex-employee at
capital one who was overseeing one of
these programs and here's what she told
me
the average credit card has 30 different
price point and reward tears and that's
on purpose they want it to be confusing
and overwhelming and they do 10 000
experiments that's a direct number she
told me on customers
you are a hamster in the maze and you
get to the cheese and you think i won i
won i got airline miles i won and then
you zoom out and you're a hamster in the
maze
on the wheel in the cycle of trying to
get more points to go on your next trip
and i just go dude become your own cash
back program save up for your trip i'll
teach you how to budget we can do this
on our own and not have to hope for some
miles to come through and the fact that
she said and you get those airline miles
and that's where the money really is and
i'm like your airline miles are worth
zero dollars you can't cash those out
yeah yeah you can cash money out of your
bank but your airline miles 100 000
miles we don't where does that get you
that's not a hundred thousand miles of
travel that's an arbitrary number that
these credit card companies use to
confuse you yeah yeah if they were so
generous they would just say all right
two percent it's gonna be full cash back
here's two thousand dollars they make it
confusing on purpose to get you to spend
and spend and spend to spend more and
more don't do this and only 48 of
americans so
you know a little less than half
pay off their credit card every month so
you hear people say you know well i
might have yeah half of those people
that say that
that's the problem with advice like this
is she's saying a blanket because i can
manage my credit card spending well
everyone should go get a credit card and
then half of america is in credit card
debt average 68 000 i'm sorry 6800
dollars
so almost 700 dollars i'm sorry gosh
seven thousand dollars
and and i'm like you know and the credit
card arguments because i'm like the math
like okay get it like sure yeah you
spend that you get okay then yes on the
on the sheet of paper i'm like yes that
that that but again what you don't take
into account is everything else we've
been talking about of how much more
you're spending how much you're just in
at their rat race of them knowing you
better than you even know yourself
um and it's and then
you know and i know some people use
their credit card to make ends meet they
literally do not make enough
to
live and so that's one reason they use
which we would say hey
you've got to cut expenses and you have
to earn extra money you can't con
continue to live in the negatives
and
and then the other is just buying a
bunch of stuff i'm like and then you end
up with almost a seven thousand dollar
balance on average for people and i'm
like and it's i think about our the
minimalists some of our friends i'm like
it is it's just it's just this american
standard of what we expect to live like
and we don't expect to live like this
we're going to do anything in our means
possible because this is the expectation
i'm like who set the bar who decided
that the credit card companies did
and here's the truth you can't spend
your way into a meaningful life
no and you sit there with your credit
card and you spend look at your
transactions how many of those were
wants versus needs don't tell me you
only spent it on gas
listen you're having some fun and that's
okay but that stuff's gonna have you if
you're not careful and you're gonna be
sitting there with credit card debt
hoping for some airline miles so that
you can go to cancun pay for your own
dang honeymoon we'll teach you how to do
this all day long dude you don't have to
wait on capital one this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by rachel
cruz and we are hitting the road rachel
our building wealth live event is coming
to las vegas and orlando this may and
building wealth is a hot topic right now
there's all kinds of opinions on how to
do it whether it's crypto single stock
zero down real estate nfds it seems like
everyone wants to get rich and quick
plus inflation has everyone freaking out
right now so join me dave ramsey rachel
cruz dr john dolone and ken coleman as
we unpack these hot topics we're going
to walk you through what's going on
today and teach you how to build real
wealth the financial principles that we
teach are the only principles that work
in prosperous times and in hard times
and we're going to show you the quickest
and surest way to become what we call a
baby steps millionaire
so get ready vegas we're coming to you
thursday may 5th in orlando we are
coming to you thursday may 19th and we
are really excited we've just confirmed
four more cities for our building wealth
events in the fall so stay tuned more on
that next week tickets started just 25
bucks or you can get a four pack of
tickets for just 60 bucks this is a
great deal don't wait tickets are flying
off the virtual shelves go to
ramsaysolutions.com
events if you want to learn more it's
such a fun event we did this in january
here in nashville yep
had about what probably 1800 people or
so and it was it's such a great
conversation to have right now and
what's going on so we're hitting all the
trending stuff and of course it points
back to our timeless principles yep so
it's going to be great vegas and orlando
good cities they chose well they did
we're gonna have some fun thanks live
events team ramseysolutions.com
events all right we're going to the
phones this hour it's a free call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
anthony joins us in bridgewater new
jersey anthony welcome to the show
hey george and rachel god bless you guys
thanks for taking my call i appreciate
it oh we appreciate that how can we help
so uh my question is around what to do
with the extra cash from selling my
house so my wife and i bought a house uh
in january 2020 right so right before
everything went crazy go ahead and
market went up um so the value of our
house went way up and um also we've
pretty much doubled our income in the
last four or so years so we were able to
afford a bigger house
yeah um so yeah we wanted to upgrade we
wanted to also move closer to parent
obviously when we have kids it's easier
for us to continue to work part-time or
my life
so we bought a new house and we're
selling our current house um and
essentially we made 150 000 from you
know when we originally bought it
and so we want to do a couple upgrades
to the house um with the extra money
we're getting but um with the remainder
i just wanted to know exactly where i
should put it so we're going to make
sure we put in at least 20 equity so we
don't you know we avoid the pmi
but also
we have about an extra thirty thousand
dollars um after everything said and
done so i was wondering should i just
put the rest of it toward the mortgage
that's what my original plan was
um i have
still
about forty thousand dollars left in
student loans so i was wondering maybe i
should put it there
get most of that out
and then lastly should i be tithing any
of this so originally i was like you
know i don't think so because it's just
all staying in housing stuff and you
know the whole market went up um but you
know god gave us the house uh right
before everything went crazy so it's
like we're able to do this you know
because of his provision so i was like
maybe we should you know tie some of
that and we have the ability to right
fifteen thousand dollars to be yeah um
the ten percent of that so just want to
know what you guys thought it's great
lots of lots of great questions yeah
some good problems to have i'll start
from the bottom and we can work our way
up so the tithing thing you know for me
i mean i think it's a
totally a personal conviction i mean you
guys really may talk about it and say
god we just we really feel led
um and those of you that have a
spiritual walk you know that feeling of
like
it may you know right or wrong but like
i just i feel like i need to do this so
that may be for you guys anthony i i
would say you know really when we talk
about tithing it really is the money
that you make from work that comes in
and we always say giving 10 so again if
you're a christian that could be in the
tithe category if you're not it could be
somewhere else but any level of
generosity
is something that we really highly
recommend so for you guys in this
specific situation
i don't think it's necessary but if you
guys really feel convicted to do that
you can't go wrong with generosity right
like you're never going to look back and
be like dang it
we why did we give that money you never
do that so if you guys are just kind of
leaning that way
um i think it's great i don't think it's
a legalistic right or wrong
um answer for me personally but yeah and
uh you were talking about what to do
with this money how much debt do you
guys have total
outside of the mortgage uh just the
student loans so just the 40 000. so
you're making 150 000 profit why not
just pay off these student loans
completely it's a good question um i
guess we could i i was thinking put it
into the mortgage just so that helps us
pay it off a lot faster avoid a lot of
interest over the years but um could
definitely do that too yeah i'm on track
to finish paying them off in about six
years so oof that's not a good plan
six years yeah
you said you doubled your income
tackling that quicker but do you have an
emergency fund
yes we do yeah so we have a five
thousand dollar emergency fund is that
three to six months of expenses or is
that a little low
no that's that's definitely low it's
okay to see more around the 20 000 want
to save up here's if i'm in your shoes
which is how i answer questions and
you're following the ramsey plan which
is why you called into this show that
means we're paying off all of our
consumer debt and we're getting a fully
funded emergency fund in place before
anything else before anything else now
ideally if you called before you got
this house i would have told you to do
that before you even jump to this house
but you've got some profit here and we
can use it wisely to set ourselves up
which means those house upgrades may
have to wait we can cash flow those
later on right now i want you to put
aside let's pay off the student loans
40k has a name sally may's name's on it
then the next 10 or 15 have the
emergency fund name on it beyond that we
can talk about cash flowing some of
these upgrades over time how much will
your down payment of the new house be
anthony because i know you guys said you
wanted to do 20 percent
yeah i'm trying to think 20 it's about
um
around 150 i think uh i
yes um so we already purchased the new
house and we're under contract for the
selling our house oh we had enough funds
to bridge the gap oh gotcha gotcha okay
so yeah i would do exactly what george
is saying because once you pay off
you know the student loans
and you do a little bit maybe 10 10
grand more whatever it is for the fully
funded emergency fund you got 100k left
which is a little less than that 20
percent so in a perfect world yes you
would have 20 but right now i think
having those things the debt payoff and
the emergency fund
going into a new house like i i think
that's one of the smartest things you
can do because then from there on you
know you guys have doubled your income
you're gonna be able to put more money
uh towards investing in towards paying
off this house even faster so
um once you get to that 20 equity
contact your mortgage lender and see if
they can drop that pmi that you're
paying if it's under that 20 percent so
you're saying you haven't put the money
down on the house yet but you've closed
on it what's going on there
so we we've closed on it we did put down
already uh 10
so 10 is already in oh
okay the rest that needs to go in would
be sixty thousand so oh that's what
we're making from the other house yeah
sixty thousand we wanted to put towards
that that's amazing well i love the idea
of paying off the house but we have to
get our ducks in a row here and that
means getting rid of the debt getting a
fully funded emergency fund in place
that's going to free up those student
loan payments that you would have been
making it's going to give you some
financial peace some foundation because
as a homeowner man you you know you know
it you're signing up for some things
there's going to be some costs
associated with this some upkeep some
maintenance obviously you want to do
some upgrades but we can cash flow those
with our newly found income because we
don't have student loans in our life
anymore
sounds good to me no yeah i appreciate
it that's a great idea
absolutely we're full of great ideas
here at the show we're full of a lot of
things rachel depending on who you ask
hopefully hopefully great ideas
that's right yeah but this housing
market is a it's a crazy one rachel and
a lot of people we've been getting a lot
of calls lately should i sell the house
a lot of people like should i sell the
house to get out of debt love the idea
not always something that i just tell
people to go jump on that today yeah
because a lot of times they go oh you
have twelve thousand dollars in debt we
can pay this off really fast we don't
have to sell the house and anthony i
mean that's a pretty he's in a
remarkable position because not only did
you buy a house
in january of 2020. like we moved into
ours november at 19 and i look back at
how i'm like by the grace of jesus i
don't even know how that even happened
but yes i'm like you bought at the
perfect time you've doubled your income
which we've heard that a lot with just
rate you know market rate going up for
people in their careers so that's
amazing i mean you're just you just have
a lot on your side anthony so when we
talk about
doing these little things that almost
can feel like an ankle biter of like oh
paying off the debt getting the
emergency fund but to get from point a
to point b to win long-term financially
and to build wealth this is the fastest
route so this is what we would do for
sure but thanks for calling appreciate
it that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books my thanks to my
wonderful co-host rachel cruz all the
folks in the booth kelly ben james you
name it andrew they're all in there and
you america thank you guys for listening
we couldn't do the show without you we
appreciate you we'll be back with you
before you know it
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by rachel cruz best-selling
author and host of the rachel cruz show
and we're here for you this hour
answering your money questions your life
questions triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
if you call and you're nice kelly will
pat you through and we can try to help
you take the right next step for your
money is she the judge she's the judge
she's the holder she holds the kelly's
the filter she's the dj do i like you do
i not kelly's confusion kelly what do
you think
yay or nay
well rusty is kicking us off he's in
mansfield ohio rusty welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thanks for having me uh thanks for
taking my call absolutely and so i
i'm getting ready to graduate college
here
um in may
and uh i'll be a pharmacist once i pass
my boards
i'm 36 my wife's 32
i have a whole bunch of student loan
debt about 342 thousand dollars in
student loan debt whoa um i have
yeah i have about 9 000 in credit cards
and we have about 34 000 tied up in cars
and then i have a personal loan
from a family member which kind of
includes a house they put down their
house as
collateral with a balloon loan so we've
just been paying the interest to kind of
live here ouch um
how much how much is that
um the house is only 51 000 but in total
with other money i owe it's about 97 98
000
so what's the total debt that you owe
uh 482 000 oh
rusty
how are you feeling are you okay
oh yeah i'm i'm all right i'm more
worried than you are listening to your
show about a year ago and uh you know i
felt like i needed to pursue the pretty
big shovel because i was almost done
with school so
um i have a job lined up i'll start uh
how much you're gonna be making my
boards
i'll be making and 108 thousand
um and that's i have a job that'll be
seven days on and seven days off so i
plan on picking up another job good good
you know yep awesome yep is that your
household income or is there more money
um my wife brings home about uh 450 a
week so
what is she doing what is that what does
that pan out to do you think she'll make
this year
um she just started this job a few
months ago so
i'm gonna say maybe around 30 to 35
somewhere in that range wait what is she
doing
she's a customer service rep for okay is
that full time
yes okay do you guys have kids
um we do not that's something else i
kind of want to throw in there um
so she we have issues so we'll probably
have to do like an ivf if we want to
have kids
so um i wasn't sure if
you know where that would fit in either
because yeah we're getting kind of older
and it's coming towards that time or
not at all so totally
wow so how can we help today
um i just i just kind of need a plan of
i guess where to start
um so the the house doesn't have to be
refinanced for another three to four
years um before they call for that bloom
loan so i wasn't sure if i should pay on
other stuff for three years or so you
get out of this house situation yeah
is it is it the house that you're living
in that has the mortgage and the loan
and everything or is it
the family members
um
my mother put her house as collateral
for this house because this house is
technically worth a little bit more so
it's her house that
is on the line i guess
and how much do you have left how much
is left on the house
oh we've just been paying the interest
so the whole amount
rusty you're gonna have to get how much
will it sell for
um i honestly don't know because here's
the deal rusty y'all are seventeen sagan
we got it in 2017 so it's been a little
while i'm sure it's probably when this
market went up a little bit but yeah i'm
sure yeah probably has so here's the
thing rusty you're in kind of a extreme
situation with everything going on in
the amount
of debt which means in order to make
movement you're going to have to make
some extreme moves and we don't always
recommend selling a home and that kind
of thing
um to get out of debt cause for some
people it's like hey you got 12 000 of
credit cards at and we're like awesome
cut everything and pay it off as fast as
possible but you i mean it's a
substantial amount almost half a million
dollars and so if you want to start
making
some big moves that's where i'm going to
start looking first and foremost it's
like where are the places that we can
make some jurassic moves um and i know
you guys want a family in the future and
that's amazing and we can definitely
talk about that later on in this call
but like you don't have kids right now
nothing's tying you down to this hat
like i would start eliminating stuff and
your cars you got thirty four thousand
dollars a car debt how is that between
both cars or is that
yes yeah that's between those between
both cars what are the cars worth
um
so we owe about a little over ten
thousand on one it's probably worth
about 12 or 13
and then we have about 23 7 on the other
one and it's about 25 worth 25 or 26.
okay
well man if i'm in your shoes i'm
feeling feeling a sense of urgency and
i'm going we are selling these cars
tomorrow and we're going to drive beater
cars we are selling this house
next month and we are going to live
somewhere that we can afford one bedroom
tiny apartment i mean like i mean i'm
talking yes making these extras this is
an emergency situation and the 9 000
credit cards at all of it so like
russell yes what george is saying and i
totally agree with like there needs to
be this sense of okay in order to make a
dent and half a million dollars of debt
we got to just make some moves and so
that's right selling the car selling the
house and then mapping out a game plan
so you're gonna make 108k
um
a year but then that's every other week
so finding a job asap of what you can do
every other week your wife's making 35
000 in this market honestly i think she
can make more i would be looking for a
different job like i would be upping i
would be making huge lifestyle changes
because when you do that what's going to
end up happening is you're going to
you're going to have all this other
margin to throw at the debt you're not
going to you guys are going to be living
on nothing everything's going to be
going towards that because if you're not
making these types of decisions you're
going to be in this for a really long
time and your pattern so far rusty not
to shame you but your patterns so far of
the decisions you guys have made with
the credit card debt the car loans your
mom taking out you know clatter on her
house with a balloon mortgage like
your whole mindset has to shift like you
have to have this realization what we've
done
has not worked so we're actually gonna
have to do the opposite of everything i
thought i was gonna do with money and so
it you and your wife together like
making this because what i would do too
is and sorry george you can jump in but
like is having your why what's your why
and for you guys to start a family and
yes and i and we've had close dear
friends go through this process multiple
friends go through the ivf process and
it's long it's exhausting it's strenuous
it's set i mean there's all that emotion
and then obviously the prayer of being
able to have a family on the other side
of that
i want that to be your why like
like sacrificing so majorly to say over
here is what we want our lives to be in
order to do that so well as stress-free
as possible with as much money in the
bank
these are the decisions we have to make
yeah and make sure your cash flowing
that ivf treatment don't go into debt
for it which means we gotta clean this
thing up and use that why listen your
life at this rate is gonna suck for 10
to 20 years i don't want that for you i
want it to suck for two years because
you got gazelle intense you sacrificed
you did everything you could for your
family for that future kid that's what i
want for you rusty i'm going to gift you
one year ramsay plus i want you and your
wife to go through all the financial
peace university videos get a game plan
get on the every dollar budget and start
attacking this thing with a vengeance
because your life depends on it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality join
this hour by rachel cruz
for the teachers out there this one is
for you you guys pour your heart and
soul into helping students every single
day and you have a bigger impact on
these kids lives than you even realize
and you deserve to be recognized and
that's why we're celebrating you during
financial literacy month we're pumped to
announce our teacher appreciation
giveaway sponsored by borrowed future
our hit documentary about the dark side
of the student loan industry so here's
the deal two lucky teachers will each
win five thousand dollars cash to use
however they'd like plus three more
teachers will each win one thousand
dollars cash and there's more don't miss
out teachers go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher for your chance to win and if
you're not a teacher please please share
this with all of the teachers that you
know and love in your life that's
ramseysolutions.com slash teacher did
you have great teachers george oh i can
remember three or four of the top my
head that were life-changing i i in my
own life like i just love teachers and
then now that my our kids are in school
emily's in first grade i'm like her
kindergarten teacher i love her first
grade teacher i love like
it's it's such a gift to have great
teachers out there so thank you teachers
we really do want to celebrate you
because the work you do it's incredible
yeah they're spending so much time with
this next generation
equipping them especially the ones
teaching our personal finance curriculum
out there oh yeah i get messages every
day from teachers and students who are
just like hey we watch the curriculum we
love it and it just i'm like there's
there's hope do you get snarky little
high school students oh yeah because
i'll get them the trolls are out there
too the the high school students yeah we
hate we i got one of them you just soak
it in they sponge they said hey my class
my class thinks you're really short
i was like good it's good that's what
you got out of all of the life-changing
wisdom i was giving you you were just
thinking that guy looks pretty short
so i've been asked to prom multiple
times oh wow would you say yesterday
no i mean no i guess i could okay hey
folks out there don't ask rachel cruz to
prom she's not going okay
winston will not allow that no he would
he would say rachel that's so sweet it's
for the kids right now for the kids no
that's not sweating no one's asking all
you high school students you're
listening you're smart ones i didn't
even go to my own prom i'm not going to
your kid your kids prom no you didn't do
problems i had no no interest
you're the one that could have asked
thank you i am the boy like like the
girls the girls we we get we're at the
mercy of if you're asked unless you're
too cool rachel i was like skateboard
punk guy like dances are lame sports is
lame skateboarding is life you know
so that's how it was but that's for
another day do you regret it no regrets
okay that's fair problems still make me
uncomfortable actually it kind of makes
me uncomfortable yeah i don't want to
think about that just the amount of
let's move on axe body spray and bo in
those rooms yikes
all right moving on bill is in atlanta
and bill needs some help bill we are
happy to help you today what's going on
hey all um i appreciate you taking my
call today i'm a big fan of you guys
absolutely what's going on
i just got a question if my wife and i
bought too much house
our take-home pay per month depending on
whether we hit our bonuses or not is 900
to 10 400 a month
okay hey speak directly into your phone
for you sounds like you're in a wind
tunnel
oh no bill still with us bill did we
lose you in the wind
can you hear me okay that's all right
okay so you got 9 900 to 10 for coming
in take home pay
how much is this mortgage
all right we yeah we're we're losing you
bill shoot bill wish we could help but
i'll give him oh there we go he's back
hi are you there there we go there you
are bill we hear you okay what's the
mortgage payment
my mortgage payment's 2100 a month it's
under contract to move in in two months
and then the property taxes are a
thousand so if you count that i think it
comes out to about 35 of my take-home
pay on a 15-year fixed okay you're on
the 15-year fixed
yeah and the house is worth we're gonna
we have 130 cash and we're going to put
save 20 for the emergency fund and then
do 10 for the
down earth for the closing cost so we
were going to put the remainder on the
home okay so you haven't closed on the
house yet
no it's just under contract do you see
you or your wife having any any raises
or bonuses going up like do you see your
income overall going up
anytime soon
it's been going up about 10 a year the
last three years okay okay
i'm not sensing like a fire here i don't
think this is a like hey back out of
this thing right now man
uh but i love that you're doing the math
going hey are we gonna have margin in
our life to do other things to pay it
off early to retire with dignity so
you're asking the right questions but 30
30
is not outrageous on a 15 year yeah i
mean yeah because it'll it'll get close
to that um
so that 25 30
range is kind of where we aim for and i
think with you guys the way you're
making it sound with your bonuses and
everything
um
that it's gonna it's gonna stay around
that or even go lower so i think i think
you're okay bill i really do i mean if
we were talking 40 45 50
it's a different story um but where you
guys are at and you said 35 yeah i mean
i think it's i i
i we recommend 25 to 30 but since your
income is going up
pretty stressful that 10 raise with both
of you guys i think that your income is
going to be able to offset that in the
near future yeah you've got a great
income going for you now if if the
numbers were very different even if the
same percentage but you make a quarter
of that or half of that i start to get
worried because there's really little
margin there but you still have you know
seven grand sitting out there to
accomplish your goals to invest to save
for college all those things so
appreciate the question get that income
up as soon as possible and you'll be in
okay shape all right we're moving on to
jordan who's in dc jordan welcome to the
show
hi jordan rachel thanks so much for
taking my call sure um so my question so
i'm a fourth year medical student
graduating in may and my wife and i are
moving out to uh san francisco in july
and so i'm graduating medical school
with 188 thousand dollars of student
debt um but we managed to share a car no
car payment we paid off our credit cards
all of my wife's student loans uh but so
we're gazelle intense we're living our
life and beans uh household income of a
little more than 60 thousand dollars um
and we're probably going to increase to
a little over a hundred thousand in july
but looking at the prices um we've had
to pause our baby steps to just save up
for moving expenses and for a second car
and the area i've heard from people is
really hard to pay off loans for med
suite or for residents so my question
for you is would you recommend in a
situation like this one moving to
arguably you know one of the most
expensive cities in the country whether
or not i should refinance my student
loans i have to get a lower interest
rate to kind of make some more traction
or should i you know just uh focus on
just trying to keep my head up of water
in san francisco and then waiting until
my
income significantly increases once i'm
attending to then uh knock out the loans
when will that happen when when will you
be
my residency program's four years so
it'll be around 2026 but you know
again we're trying to make as much
traction as we can to like not knock as
much as you can out before that
um but again it's just a really
expensive part of the country so
uh just curious about what your thoughts
are about refinancing to make sure that
more of whatever we are we are able to
pay it's actually going straight towards
principles just because our right now i
have student uh loans about like through
the government and they range anywhere
from like five to seven point six
percent and you know they're insured by
the government so if something were to
happen to me if it would be forgiven it
wouldn't be my wife whereas if we
refinance maybe a lower interest rate
but then
i have to be worried about something
that happened to me would my wife be
like stuck with that um with that
balance as well and there's no chance
for that to be uh kind of uh forgiven in
any way or relinquished rather well let
me i'll talk you through my parameters
of when it makes sense to refinance on
your student loans number one it's got
to be completely free to make the change
so no fees okay i want you to keep a
fixed rate
or replace a variable rate sounds like
they're all fixed rate right
okay and i don't want you to sign up for
a longer repayment period
because that's how they get you
sometimes they go hey you're on a
four-year plan we're going to put you on
the 10-year plan and of course i want
the new interest rate to be lower than
the current one and so the place that we
recommend the folks that we recommend is
splash financial you can jump on
ramseysolutions.com and click on trusted
pros and i would get in touch with them
and see what they can offer you when it
comes to refinancing
like you said it doesn't sound like
you're looking for the shortcut here
you're just looking to make a little bit
more traction and that is the spirit
when it comes to refinancing it's not a
shortcut you're just moving the debt
around but if we can lower the interest
rate a little bit shave off a little bit
of money here and pay off that debt
faster i'm here for it and the awesome
thing is jordan if you guys because you
guys i mean you sound incredible you
you're like we have one car we've paid
off our debt my wife
yes and so you know even making this
100k
a year
finding what you can to throw at this
188 because by the time you get out of
residency and all that and you're making
significantly more how amazing would it
be just to have all of that money
jump start your investing and all of it
i mean so the sacrifice you can make now
you're gonna be able to actually enjoy
your income once it starts going up
later on down the road that's huge these
student loans are a plague on society
we've got to do something about it and
it starts with you
getting rid of them avoiding them that
is how we attack this problem this is
the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls about life and money
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
jason joins us up next he's in santa fe
new mexico jason welcome to the ramsay
show
hey guys thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on yeah so
my question would be is is now a good
time to buy or would i continue to rent
um i currently make 87 000 a year i'm
21. i have no debt i have a daughter and
a fiance and uh we're really excited to
take this new step
wow what are you doing for work
so i just got my degree in robotics um i
work in a laboratory so i'm going to be
a senior mechanical technologist good
for you man just just curious did you
get a four-year degree what was the
education like
no actually i got a two-year associate's
in applied science and robotics and i've
just been an engineering intern for a
few years at a different laboratory in
las alamos thank you jason my bachelor's
mechanically and you're making almost 90
grand at 21. my point was to say good
for you just where are we clapping for
remember jason is 21. he makes 87 000
and he got a two-year degree
so shut up there we go he's probably
very smart too jason i probably you've
got it you probably wouldn't hire me for
that robotics that's amazing okay uh do
you have any debt
uh like 3 000 but we have a little over
12k saved do you have 12 000 to your
name what's the 3 000 in debt
uh so we just had a baby um we just
traded in the car and got a new jedi so
so it's a car loan that's right yeah
yeah yeah it's a car loan okay what's
holding you back from just paying that
thing off today
um yeah i mean so i just got the new job
offer i start in the beginning of may
this has all kind of happened quick so
yeah we did just get the car
i know the market's really bad to buy i
just am not sure if i want to like walk
in and buy a house and then just
depreciate over the next few years or if
we should just continue to rent for a
little bit longer well you don't have
any money to buy a house it sounds like
yeah that's that's what i was thinking
too but i guess in the future would it
be better to to just do a six to one
year um lease and just rent and just try
to save up as much as we can
i mean i'm a big fan of renting if it's
buying you patience to get into that
house the right way
if that's what you're saying okay
yeah so that no that's that's what i've
been trying to sell my mom but she
usually oh okay now mom's involved yeah
she's making financial decisions the
thing is is everyone's like you need to
buy a house you need to buy a house you
have a baby jason you have a fiance you
need to buy a house you got a great job
now you need to buy a house buy house by
house you can't rent with a baby rachel
it's illegal in new mexico oh my gosh
so no but the pressure to buy a home it
is so great but listen the market right
now is insane so if you do not have to
buy a home right now and you don't have
the cash flow and the means to be smart
about it no i think renting is 1 000
okay it is not just throwing your money
away you're buying time to save up so if
i were you
paying off this car loan is 3 000 and
then i would take the rest of your 10
grand or 9 grand that you'll have left
and have it for an emergency fund so you
guys basically are you know and if you
need a little bit more to do that three
to six months of expenses then add to
that and then start saving for a down
payment so we recommend anywhere from 10
to 20 percent to put down so that can be
y'all's next goal is to say hey over the
next three years two years we're gonna
be saving
for a down payment on a home and then
the beautiful thing is when you actually
go to purchase it maybe in two years the
market could have corrected itself a
little bit yeah at the top that would be
nice so jason our parameters here you
can jump onto ramseysolutions.com and go
to the mortgage calculator under the
free tools and start playing around with
that and start to see okay if i do a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage which is the
only type that i'd have ever recommend
to you and we want
the payment to be no more than a quarter
of our take-home pay then we can go okay
how much house can we get based on us
putting 10 to 20 down
that helps you kind of get a ballpark
for what house you're looking at versus
letting realtor.com or zillow decide or
the bank even worse decide how much
house you should get
okay great now yeah thank you guys for
uh taking the time to answer my question
absolutely man thanks for the call the
pressure from the mom it's a real thing
i knew there was a mom moms moms are
great
but man they really they want the best
even if it's not always the best even if
it means putting their kids in crippling
debt to do it
oh boy all right let's move on to morgan
she's in shelbyville tennessee morgan
welcome to the show
hi it's good to talk to y'all you too
what's going on
i am leading my first fpu class right
now we just finished lesson four
um i'm super pumped about it but my
class is all live
no husbands
attending participating anything
so i was wondering if y'all had any
advice like how i can encourage them
better and
push them to keep going because i'm not
married myself so i can't i can only
imagine how difficult it is to try to do
something like this on your own yeah so
what were the husbands invited i have to
ask
yes i mean yeah as far as i know um i
don't know did the husband see it like
oh well this is girl's night no thank
you
no i don't think so now some of them
have told me that they have well several
of them actually have told me they have
their finances separate
so i don't know if that's
part yeah of course that's part of the
problem but um i know another husband
her the wife is just like hey
leave me out of this do whatever you
want
so
no sounds like a gym
man well it's a common thing i mean the
the idea of
being on separate pages doing your own
thing and husband's feeling like i think
i'm good i got this money stuff taken
care of yeah i mean it is it's so normal
so i appreciate you even asking the
question morgan and seeing it and being
like man i wish i wish it would be
different
um you know i mean if they're just not
willing to go you can't make someone do
anything
that took me all right lots of
counseling sessions to really understand
you can't control people the best way to
support the wives is to encourage them
to have the right conversation with the
husbands going hey this matters to me i
don't feel financially safe
i want to grow in this area and i want
you to come along this journey with me
it's not hey you're going to go to this
class because dave said and you you
stink with money it can't be like that
it has to be a warmer invitation but
also very firm saying this is something
that i need you to be on board with
because we are not in a great financial
position i want us to be better
financially i want to do this together
as a team that's what marriage is that's
what you signed up for when you decided
to say i do
and so that's the kind of conversation
they need to have with their husbands uh
there's not a lot you can do personally
to have that conversation for them
yeah and i think i did talk to them
about like having a big why and we just
finished lesson four so they talked
about the dream meeting having the dream
meeting about what the future looks like
that's kind of stupid watching that
alone while your husband's at home well
that's what i just don't want them to
feel defeated or like they can't do it
even though i'm sure it's much harder
but yeah i still want them to feel like
they can do it yeah and i and i think
you know
encouraging them and it's so interesting
that the whole class that like no
husband is coming right so it really is
all these
wives and so i think that's a possibly a
good thing because you guys can kind of
brainstorm i think as a group even
and and i think for two i think
sometimes the conversation around money
with couples
and with women
they can almost make it seem like oh i
really want you to come to this thing
but like oh i don't know it and it feels
just kind of like
surfacy feeling but if they really get
under and be like listen i
i'm struggling because i'm feeling like
if we're gonna be separate on this
there's other areas of our marriage i
want our marriage to be the best richest
marriage possible and being on one team
or i feel lonely doing this by myself
and i want my husband there like start
to put the weight of it not nagging but
putting the weight of what they're
feeling in it to their husbands
um i think is a for them to have a real
serious conversation about it and
you know dr john dolone always says it
and i think he's right that if it gets
to a point that they just will not
that's when you bring in a third party
yeah and you bring in someone because
because again it's a it's a red flag in
other areas of marriage when there's not
a level of hey
um i want to come in as one now
opposites attract so in any marriage
there's gonna be one that's gonna be way
more excited than the other and i know
for us what's funny is like my husband
is actually the one that's more excited
about this stuff than i even am even
though this is my job but he's like he
has the excel sheets he knows all the
number i mean he's like checking
everything he i mean it is like in his
head and i'm and i'm not as great at
details so i'm like okay i'm having to
go back in and relook at stuff so
naturally there's me one more excited
than the other and that's not right or
wrong but if they won't even come to the
table and have a discussion and talk
about it
that's where the red flag comes in so um
i think you morgan encouraging them is
awesome get the wives to say hey we're
gonna watch this video at home together
first lesson just to get them on the
great idea and then see if they'll come
to a class but man
men step up dudes and it might be
intimidating be like oh man i'm going to
be going with sarah and mary all your
friends
you know so maybe the home thing that's
okay that's a great suggestion you know
it's weight in the waters a little bit i
like that but overall men need to step
up this is ridiculous yes thank you so
much for leading the class we appreciate
all of our financial peace coordinators
out there leading the charge on the home
front
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america this is the ramsay
show i'm george campbell joined by
rachel cruz this hour and we are taking
your calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five
ava joins us up next she's in buffalo
new york ava welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
um so i've been offered an internship
over the summer
and i'm conflicted about whether or not
i should take it because it's by my
college town and
um my mom wants me to come back home
because i won't have to pay any bills
over the summer and i also have a job
for the summer lined up there
but um
it's not as uh related to what i want to
go into as this one is this one's kind
of just more
suited to my career and i'm just not
sure if i should heed my mom's advice or
stay
um in my college town and take this
internship this summer
um so what are you what did you study
i'm in biology okay and what's the
internship
um so it's like a lab scientist intern
i'd be shadowing um
some people in a lab learning techniques
and um learning how to become a better
science communicator and
um
yeah and that excites you
yeah but it's unpaid
it is paid it pays 18 an hour okay
this is better so you'll be able to pay
your bills
if you do this internship
i found um an apartment i'd be able to
live in for only 300 a month which like
um with the inflation and everything and
especially in this area is a really good
deal yeah that's amazing is it in a safe
part of town
is it legit yes it is
yeah it's um it's actually
near the off-campus living um apartments
where i am now okay and the alternative
is what what is this job back home that
you have for the summer
so it's also in a lab but i'm doing
i don't know how to put it i'm doing
more menial work if that makes sense the
um the job that i would be doing um over
the summer here would be much more i
would have to use my brain i would have
to think i would have to know more
hands-on
yeah the job back at home is like
i'm kind of answering phones more which
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
like i
don't feel like it would directly be
benefiting my career yeah does it pay
more ava does it pay more i'm trying to
understand yeah
the one at home pays 15 an hour
but um there's also another so i have a
family member who's pretty sick right
now living back at home
and it's that's another major reason i
haven't just said yes yet like
she's pretty sick and i haven't been
able to see her and i would only really
i wouldn't get to see her because she's
too sick to come to me so
to visit where where's college versus
home how far away
six hours
okay
could you go visit a few weekends over
the summer back home
uh possibly i would i would definitely
want to i would definitely try to work
that out or if i could even take i don't
know a weekend or a longer weekend yeah
so ava what's what's the big pull for
your i'm just curious from your mom's
perspective because you guys disagree on
this is it what's her main motivation
for wanting you back home is it just to
have you again is it because of the sick
family member is it because
bills yeah what what's her main
motivation
or reason why she's saying
the rent she's like you we can't
um we're not going to be like supporting
you
um you know over the summer because my
parents are helping me pay for college
but um
i do uh i would be paying my rent by
myself which i i could do that if i had
this job it would only i calculated my
expenses and everything i would be able
to do that and still make more money
yeah i feel like you have that
respectful conversation with mom and go
hey mom i really appreciate it thank you
for wanting me to come home and do all
this but i've done the math here and i
can make this work very easily and this
internship is going to get me closer to
what i want to be doing in my career and
here's the deal i'm going to come visit
at least twice this summer to come be
with you guys and see this sick relative
and you do that in a respectful way and
then mom doesn't really get a say in
your life at this point i mean they're
paying for college right respectful of
that yeah so i'm just thinking like ava
you're not doing anything okay i'll say
this
one way or the other it's not gonna be a
life-shattering decision if you did
decide to go and do this it's not your
ideal it's not really what you want but
if you did it's you're going to be fine
you're going to be fine if you take the
internship right but
um
you're a very smart
young woman as you're talking through
all your expenses you've run the
calculations like you've done your work
your due diligence to
create a pretty great argument in a
sense of like hey here's what i want to
do and it makes sense you're not off
just like hanging out at the pool all
summer and expecting them to pay your
bills right like there's there's no
you really are taking a lot of
responsibility so in a in a respectful
way i would do what george said and talk
to her and um
and it but you know it's hard at your
age too because they do have this like
there's a little bit of shadow yeah
because they're paying your bills and so
or not paying your bills in this but the
tuition for college but that's my other
thing is but i would argue back to her
is that like you're not doing anything
immoral or wrong
and so there shouldn't i pray that that
doesn't become part of the discussion of
just you know that that they feel
any like ungratefulness from you you
know because they pay your tuition all
that so i think it comes with a lot of
humility a lot of gratitude
in it and that this is what you want to
do so i think it's a it's a good it's a
good conflict to have as you're starting
to kind of start to be out on your own
but if i'm your mom i'm proud of you
um should i be worried about the family
member like should that be part of my
decision would you say
how close are you with them is it um
is it something that you would regret do
you think that you'll look back in five
years and say man i wish i spent my
summer closer to them
i don't know because she's so
it feels like a mental health disorder
but
it has a pretty high mortality rate and
it just makes me like
i think about her all the time because
it just literally eats away at people
who have it and it's
like
it's just so bad and like i feel and
that's like my main
pull because honestly the rent works
itself out i could do the rent by myself
but i feel like if i leave this person
and she were to like not
make it i would be like really
i feel really bad that i didn't spend
the last couple days with her
yeah no i hear that absolutely so i mean
yeah because this ads definitely this
definitely adds to the decision and just
hearing you even now as you're
processing and i'm like oh wow this is a
it is a heavy thing for you it doesn't
feel like an obligation you know
anything like that and you i think you
genuinely
want to be there for this family member
and so
you know that could be a thing how old
are you ava
i'm 20. you're 20 yeah
um
i feel like at this point there's going
to be more regret if you go to the
college town do the internship and don't
go home then if you just went home do
the internship you can still have the
career you want get the experience you
want later on what does the family
member have can i ask
she's anorexic and she's getting worse
oh so sorry
he's getting worse oh i'm sorry ava
gosh
man i'm so sorry
i don't mean anything
he doesn't let my parents look at what
she eats she doesn't it's horrible and
it's getting worse every single day
and she's direct family
yeah oh i'm so sorry
that's heartbreaking i wonder if that's
part of mom's
you know advice is she wants you to be
home and she needs the support
on top of wanting to help you with the
bills
and she's using me coming home as a
reason not to go to treatment
oh
well
she's using a reason for you not to go
home as not to go to treatment but if
you came home she would go to treatment
no she's saying but she doesn't want to
go to treatment because she thinks i'm
going to come home so she doesn't want
to be in the center over the summer
while i'm home
and that's her like thing that she's
saying but if i don't i feel like it'd
be even worse if i wasn't there because
i feel like she'd make the excuse either
way not to go
yeah yeah i think it's something like
this it's not and it's not it's not up
to you ava okay i don't want you to have
this heroic mindset that you're gonna be
able to change
you can be there for support but that
um but it does sound like being close um
if that if that's something that you
feel like you'll regret yours and down
the road i'm telling you for three
months you may you may want to consider
that going home just to be there but i'm
so sorry
i'm so sorry that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
i'm ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by rachel cruz and we are
excited to take your calls about your
life and your money so give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
sarah's kicking off this hour she's in
los angeles sarah welcome to the ramsay
show
[Music]
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
so my husband okay um
we currently own our house um
if we sold it it would be right around
580 to 600.
we owe
238 000 on it
um
we don't plan on staying in california
we would like to run out of here as fast
as we can
but that's not going to be for about
another year
so we're thinking of selling our house
moving the family into a fifth wheel
because the market's so high and we
still have so much equity here we can
place the trailer at my in-laws house
and they have a couple of acres and we
would just be paying utilities
we plan on selling our house in about a
year anyways so ultimately we're just
worried that if the market drops we'll
lose everything that god has blessed us
with would it be better to sell high or
keep it as an asset
well what's the issue with keeping the
house right now
um it's not an issue i mean we're more
than
fine to stay here um we purchased the
house really low
but just fearful that it's going to go
down do you want to get out of
california or is it we we love this
house we just want to move to the
trailer like what's the what's the heart
behind it
uh no we want to get out of california
like i said we would run there if we
could but as of right now
i'm finishing school so i should be done
so you have to stay like something so
sarah why don't y'all move to an
apartment for a year if you if you
really are that fearful with it going
down the market you know correcting
itself like going down or whatever and
then you lose all this equity because
you know you're for sure going to leave
you know for sure i'm leaving in 12
months
to go somewhere else
why why like the mobile home situation
why not just go
rent an apartment for a year it feels
like a lot of sacrifice when you don't
really need to be
so that's kind of why we're on the edge
about it so we do have two kids both
under the age of 10
and we have two dogs so everyone i mean
all my heartbeats are going with us
and so to find an apartment that would
be a lot and
we
ultimately like before we wanted to move
we wanted to buy a trailer we were
saving up for um a toy hauler trailer
because we go camping and we do all that
stuff so i was thinking well
if we just do it now we can live in
there for about six to eight months
until we're ready to move and i mean
let's say we find land in tennessee that
we want where you can at least stay in
the trailer while the house is being
built or
we go to arizona because either way
we're going to places where my husband
can transfer for work sure
so that's sarah our ultimate
we always say we do not make financial
decisions when we're fearful or when
we're drunk because
never turns out good either way so
it's a very fear-based decision is what
you're doing none of this is hurting you
guys financially
um i don't think now the conspiracy
theorist in me could go a lot of
different ways but if i'm level-headed
right now can we mute her like there's
no there's a you know there there's no
indication that it's absolutely going to
crash is the market going to correct
itself eventually but you're in l.a it
hasn't corrected itself since like i
don't know the pool i don't think you
need to worry about i think you're
losing i really think you're fine and
sarah honestly it kind of sounds
miserable being with two kids and two
dogs and a husband in a camper
does that sound like tough to you
it sounds awesome you're a better woman
than me i don't know maybe i'm just not
very
you're not candy outdoorsy but my mom
said the same thing no you have to pay
me to go on that reality show if y'all i
mean this it's not right or wrong if you
guys want to because it sounds like an
adventure and all this and you're going
to move anyways i mean y'all can
but it's really you're really making
this decision completely out of fear
with no indication of anything else so
i wouldn't i would stay put where you
are and then in a year six months eight
months whatever you said that you're
that you're done with school you guys go
find a place you're going to be shocked
when you sell this house you're going to
get 600 grand for it you said it could
even go up from now who knows and then
you're going to get
you're going to find much cheaper places
in your trailer which is a depreciating
asset come to nashville it's where
everyone from california is coming and
oh some people are saying no people
there's no more room you're welcome
everyone's like no sarah here's the
other problem you're buying a trailer at
the top of the market too
so you're gonna pay top dollar for that
trailer that's gonna depreciate in value
the day you buy it
while letting go of an appreciating
asset and so that's one of the reasons
of many i wouldn't do this right now i'm
not mad at you living in the fifth wheel
and having a good time with the family
but right now you don't have to do that
i'd finish school stay in the house stay
put you're gonna be okay when it's time
to move out of california you can do
that you're gonna have plenty of equity
you're gonna have paid down the house
even further while it's still holding
value or appreciating
okay
sarah but if you want if you yeah i
think it is great advice but if you want
to go to the camper and that's where
your heart is and that's where you and
yourself we deflated sarah all of her
dreams camping with the dogs and the
kids dad you're so sad how about this
sarah how about you take a long weekend
or a week and go camping in a trailer
with the family
without having to buy it all and move
your whole family and sell the house and
all the stuff that goes along with that
yeah that's an idea and then if you love
it you go we could do this for the next
year just live in this camper and trail
then it's it's a different situation but
right now i feel like it's a it feels
like a rash decision and we're making
some justifications and you're not in a
terrible financial spot where i go you
got to get out of this house asap
yeah we're definitely not and the house
is great my husband and i make enough to
cover it but
uh i don't know
like i said i'm on a run from california
as fast as i can well can you run now i
mean can you still do your school you do
it online
no so i um i found a work program so
they're actually paying me to work okay
and uh my hours are accumulating yeah
you're going to still be
okay you're still going to be in a
camper in california though so your
change of california doesn't really
still in california at the end of the
day yeah
well thanks for the question appreciate
that
rachel i'm real excited we're just days
away from the launch of dr john dolone's
book we've been talking about it a lot
on the show
but it's called own your past change
your future
and with that we've got a really cool
bonus right now you get a month of free
one-on-one weekly therapy when you
pre-order a copy that's incredible
you're never too old you're never too
young to improve your health and make
your relationship stronger and this is
going to give you the tools you need to
change your future along with the book
you're going to get the ebook the
audiobook read by john himself and of
course that free month of one-on-one
weekly therapy from our friends at
betterhelp so check that out this book's
going to make you laugh it's going to
make you cry it will challenge you and
when you take the steps that dr deloney
outlines and take advantage of this free
therapy you will be transformed rachel i
know you're a big fan of people seeking
counseling and seeking their no i do i
love it it's huge because yeah and john
does such a great job bringing such a
human aspect to this because it kind of
can be a for some people like a weird
topic a heavy topic they're like oh
but there's just growth right where you
you're learning how to handle your money
better hopefully you're learning about
your marriage if you're married and
parenting like all these aspects of our
life including yourself what makes you
tick why are you doing what you're doing
and learning that is so great and he and
he outlines it beautifully so that's
huge yeah just 20 years of experience
and his phds and he packs it into a
conversational book to help us all grow
personally go check it out it's just 20.
ramsay solutions.com you get all those
bonuses all those goodies if you do it
before the book launches and we're about
a week away that's crazy okay go check
it out ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you that means they check in every year
with free consultations to help you stay
on the right plan they show you how to
save money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchill
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by rachel
cruz it's a free call triple eight eight
two five five two two five
mark joins us next all the way from
anchorage alaska mark welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thanks for having me on the show
absolutely what's going on with you
so
just a quick snapshot in february of
2020 i had 283 000 of student loan debt
wow
i was engaged and so me and my wife went
to financial pc university then
and since then so now we're down to 49
000. wow wow amazing
so you paid down almost 240 000 dollars
yep since then so we've been going
pretty seriously that's incredible in a
short amount of time good for you
yeah and so i guess my question is i'm
down to 49 my my work pays 20 000 a year
and they've done that the last two years
that i've been doing this so 40 000 was
from them so my question is should i get
down to the last 40 and just let my
works
finish it off
or just keep going what are the
stipulations of this payoff is it as
long as you're employed here will pay
off 20 grand for the year
it's a one-year contract agreement yeah
so i just say i'll work here for one
more year and then they give me 20 000.
and when do you start when did you sign
that when was like the or the last one
well so the last one i just signed so
the next 20 will be coming really soon
okay so this is april so you'll probably
be with them obviously you have to be
with them through next april for them to
pay it
well they give it to me up front and
then if i left early i would have to pay
him back oh okay okay is there interest
with the payback
or is it just doing
well
well they they give me a little bit more
than 24 and it gets or they give me like
24 and it gets taxed so if i pay them
back i have to pay back like 24. gotcha
got it it doesn't sound like a terrible
plan you're not stuck in a five ten year
contract but i wouldn't sleep just one
year to one year yeah and i i would not
because i mean you guys have been
killing it so i'm like i wouldn't slow
down paying it off to wait for next year
so if they so you had 49 left and if
they're going to pay another 20
um yeah 29 i mean you're saying you want
to get it down to 40 and then they'll
just pay it off for the two years
right exactly and then we could start
you know build our emergency fund and
then start paying for a house because
we're in an apartment now
it's an interesting predicament
i mean it doesn't sound like a bad deal
sometimes these student loan repayment
programs through employers are a little
scary of all the stipulations and the
red tape and the strings attached this
one doesn't sound like there's a lot
there it doesn't but i just know how
how much progress you all make mark like
i'm like man if you just continue down
this road you wouldn't have you you
wouldn't be done with it this year quote
unquote handcuffed to a job for two
years you are for one technically i
guess with this 20 grand
but you could knock off the rest um
income
household
well oh sorry it's uh 160.
okay
i mean this thing could be gone this
year and i i think it's a cool benefit
from the employer and it feels like well
there's so much i'm missing out on free
20 grand but i also see
debt freedom months from now and you
have the emergency fund and you're
investing and i think there's there's a
net gain uh on that side too that needs
to be acknowledged
yeah that's kind of where our
where are they how quickly could you pay
this thing off if it was just on you
well which with well because i already
signed this other 20. so with that and
we were planning on being done
august at the latest july if we really
got after it that's amazing
i mean i would because you could have
your emergency fund i mean you guys
could be through baby step three on 3b
by the time this next contract would be
up you know so what's your what's your
future goals financially
financial well i
i mean we want to have a big down
payment as for a house as we can so we
want to do that and then later i mean we
just want to
live and you want to stay in anchorage
you want to stay with this employer in
this job yeah right yeah that's the
thing too i have no no problem here and
we like it here so
yeah
well i'd strongly consider
getting you know let them do this 20 but
beyond that just get rid of it in the
next few months get the emergency fund
start working on the down payment i just
feel like your goals are too important
for for the remaining 20 grand to be
paid when you make 160.
so that's my take okay i'm taking what i
can get right now but i'm also attacking
it with a vengeance and moving on with
my life
right
y'all are doing great though mark
awesome job that's pretty incredible
absolutely amazing thanks for the call
we're moving on over to louisville
kentucky megan joins us there megan how
are you
hey good thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
well
my husband and i are debt-free except
for our house
and we've been
[Music]
working actually we've been a little bit
disagreeing i've wanted to throw
everything at the house
and we do want to buy land and build a
house
preferably as soon as possible but
he uh he wants us to kind of throw
everything at
building up money
to do that
he just came my direction and said okay
okay we'll throw everything at the house
and now
i'm second guessing myself and going
should we throw everything at
making a fund to buy land and build a
house so what is the order when you're
going to sell the house to get the land
i mean eventually we would yes but my
concern
would be that all of our money would be
in equity in the house and as soon as we
sell it then
all we have is land and no no house so
well if you can only afford the land to
no house then you're not ready to buy
the land you're trying to buy the land
while still living in the house and then
build this other house while you're
still living in this house correct okay
yes and yes you're right what i'm asking
is that we would want to
buy land when we have the money we would
want to build a house when we have the
money
we can't do either of those
while you have your current house
yeah yeah you'll want to sell your house
and rent somewhere
okay i guess we were hoping to not rent
somewhere i didn't know if you just
because we would be
we would end up putting
more into rent than what
even if we had all the equity in our
house and we sold it for 100 equity and
we were in an apartment
we would be paying so much more than
what we have been on our mortgage yeah
but it's not the monthly payments that's
the concern it's the amount of money
that you take then to put and buy a land
have a down payment as you guys start
the build process you know what i'm
saying like you need
that chunk of money to be able to start
that process so what's it going to cost
for the land plus the build
i i don't know yet we don't have a
particular we don't have a specific plot
of land in mind because we've just
gotten to the point where we could
gotcha this could be a few years away
it could be yeah um that's why so with
all the with this time say we're looking
at three years
um i didn't know if i should put a
portion like have a separate fund where
i'm not throwing every single thing at
the house but i but i want the house
paid off i mean we've been doing this
dave ramsey thing how close are you to
having the house paid off
um
if we were hard hardcore
on paper we have 20 years but if we were
hardcore i think we could do it in four
years okay so why not go at this house
and in four years you have a fully paid
for house
that's appreciated and so it's a for
savings account on that front and then
you cash out with 100 equity
and you can buy the land build and like
rachel's saying if you want to keep
living in the house you know there are
ways to do that with kind of rent back
programs and things like that from the
new buyer but it feels like this build
is gonna this is a long process to buy
land and build on it
yeah
yeah and it's still kind of a dream
again like if there was if you guys had
like hey there's a specific neighborhood
a specific lot and you had like or or a
plot of land that you know of that
you're like this is what we want it's up
for sale like if there were actionable
things um it could be but it still kind
of just feels like a dream which is an
awesome dream and a dream that you guys
1000 can do and you can even do before
it's a paid for house like but but as of
now um
i would put it yes i would still put it
towards my mortgage and be paying it off
um
because also there's a chance that that
dream changes in two years right like
who knows the world we're gonna be
living in in two years
that savings fund turns into the i want
the new car fund and i want to upgrade
this fund and you lose that money yeah i
would i would just yeah i continue what
you guys are doing you're doing a great
job and either way you're gonna come out
on the other side okay whether it's with
equity or cash in a bank in a savings
account yeah but nothing wrong with
throwing it at the house that's a nice
for savings plan and uh with homes the
way they are it's just going to keep
appreciating so good luck with that
whole process megan this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by rachel cruz
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window covering you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every single month
you're gonna save even more just use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from anthony in
ohio i've recently reached a 50 000
savings goal
for a down payment on a home that i plan
to purchase next year before i pull the
trigger i was considering giving my
recent college grad son a gift of zero
debt and wipe out his thirty thousand
dollars in student loan debt
if i did this i plan to replace the
money
the my plan to replace the money would
be to borrow from my 401k savings plan
no no no as alone
not a withdrawal and payback over time
my 401k currently has about five hundred
thousand dollars in it i'm 47 and i plan
to work another 20 years the only
downside i see
it would be taking money out of the
market is that okay to do for my son
anthony your heart is great sweet let's
talk about that
great
great heart your heart is great your
plan is terrible
that's that's how i feel this is a
terrible option do not do the 401k loan
uh you're right that you're taking money
out of the market you are robbing
yourself
but your 401k is for retirement people
let me remind you it's not for
emergencies it's not for getting rid of
debt it's not for going on vacation and
it's not to get your son out of debt
he's gonna be okay he signed up for 30
grand in student loan debt what happens
is you do this
and all of a sudden you're not set up
for retirement you don't hit your
financial goals and now you need your
kids to help in your old age and his
son's gonna be calling us going my dad
took out a 401k loan to pay off my
student loan debt but now he's broke and
i'm trying to help him that was the
kinds of calls we get or my dad had to
leave his job and now he owes all that
debt back as a 401k loan if you leave
the job it's owed at the next tax period
so he's going to be saying yeah you have
your goals and you have 50 000 saved for
the down payment and you've got to stay
on the course for that goal so on top of
robbing yourself with these 401k loans
here's what we found rachel our state of
personal finance research that our team
did
seven out of ten people who borrowed
from their 401k in the past year because
of covid said they regretted that
decision and on top of that more than
half of americans 56 percent now feel
that they're behind on retirement goals
so on top of robbing from your
retirement there's stress involved and
if you leave your job for any reason you
have until next year's tax filing to pay
that back in full the entire balance and
i don't like you being that dependent on
your employer yeah so so anthony i mean
if this is something you wanted to do
right like the the idea with parents in
college we always say if you are able to
help your kids go through college that
is a blessing that is a gift it is not a
requirement as a parent to do that but
that's a beautiful legacy to leave right
so you as the dad was like okay i wasn't
able obviously to help him he went
thirty thousand dollars in student loan
debt so if it's in your heart that
you're like man i would love to help my
son pay the set off then do it i think
that's great but don't do it out of a
401k loan and if you have the ability
because you you probably make great
money when you have half a million
dollars in your retirement which is
awesome so if you do have margin and you
do have the ability to say hey
hey son i would love to
you know gift you 15 that i'd love to
help pay off fifteen thousand dollars of
your day whatever right like with your
own money outside of everything else
with cash and you can
you know as long as you're not enabling
them and that's a whole other discussion
but um i think that that's fine that's a
that's a gift that's a blessing to do
that but don't do it through a 401k loan
there's too many people out there who
feel like a 401k loan isn't really debt
rachel i'm just so i'm just paying
myself back no biggie it's not debt you
pay taxes twice right yes and that's a
whole other piece you're paying taxes
twice a year here's how it works the
repayments are made with after-tax
dollars you following me so the money
that's going in has already been taxed
and then you're gonna pay taxes on that
money again when you make withdrawals in
retirement
now i'm fine uncle sam taxed me once
that already stings enough twice is just
insult to injury
don't do this save up pay cash the 401k
loan is not your emergency fund it's not
your getting out of debt fund it's to
help you cover retirement thanks so much
for the question anthony do the right
thing
brandon joins us up next he is down the
street here in nashville tennessee
brandon welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me great what's
going on um
so basically i'm calling because i'm 24
i
recently married last year of june we
have a five month year old kid oh
congratulations
eight thanks and um i am scared for
myself i know that i haven't been doing
the best
i am trying though every single time um
i just scheduled an army in january um i
got a good job that it's so good that's
my on staying there for life in portland
tennessee
and um i'm making about
six about 6 500 a month 2300 of that is
from the va tax-free
i'm in 64 000 in debt and 52 000 of that
is vehicles which is a truck and a car
and 12 000 of that is credit cards
every paycheck i get paid weekly i
put money in the savings and i pay
everything as much as i can aside from
that take care of the family but i'm
getting scared because i don't
i have a problem where
i have a spending problem my wife is
great she's more the savings person and
i have this problem where if i see
something
i'm afraid if i don't get it then
i'll never get it again or i'll never
have the opportunity
and
force about of the 6 500 a month about 4
000 of that
goes away to all that stuff and i want
to be
eat yeah i'm i'm all right i'm
struggling to where i mean i have money
i'm surviving taking care of the family
good but obviously i'm not you are worth
more than surviving brandon and thank
you so much for your service to this
country yeah absolutely so here's the
deal
you are a dad now
this is not 21 year old brandon having a
good time living his life this is
brandon as a father as a husband and
that means we have to make adult
decisions and that means these vehicles
are probably gone this week
and it means we're not going to have the
fanciest newest toys we're gonna drive a
beater car because we have to get our
fan our family to financial safety and i
can feel that fear in your voice you
told me you're scared so are you willing
to do something so that you can remove
this fear and stress out of your life
so here's here's the thing um one before
i go to the vehicles um we're moving in
on april 21st and
that's where we had nine thousand
savings you guys are probably gonna be
mad at me for this i'm not mad at you uh
we we had no furniture right now we're
living in a place where it's
life-threatening to where i wouldn't say
life-threatening but it's very
disgusting we are very organized
everything but my family is living with
roaches thankfully the kid can't crawl
yet and
the renter guy he just it's all under
the table i mean he's nice he's a good
guy but he's lazy
so we're moving immediately to a very
nice place very nice apartment complex
so that's where all the money went
there's buying i outright bought
a very good bed couch everything that we
need to survive and live comfortably um
back to the vehicles i am willing to but
i'm also scared because okay my dream my
dream vehicle is it's coma and i have it
i got it brand new 2020. you're living
the nightmare dude brandon you can get
it to come later there's there's there's
lots of tacomas if this was such a dream
you wouldn't be calling us so so brandon
i hear such a scarcity mindset with you
so here's what i want to reset
all of this the decisions that we're
going to be talking about in this phone
call it's for a short period of time
okay the i feel like the ramsay show the
brand gets such a bad rap sometimes
someone's like you just want people
driving crappy cars and not going on
vacation no the slogan is you live like
no one else so later you get to live and
give like no one else these sacrifices
branded is not for your entire life if
we told you to do it for your entire
life we'd be crazy i wouldn't listen to
us this is for a short period of time
for a few years of your life you're
gonna get your crap cleaned up you're
gonna feel the best the most peace you
have ever felt as a man to be able to
take care of your family with cash in
the bank living in a good spot maybe not
driving your dream car all that's gonna
be settled
then you get to say wow brandon i really
want a tacoma guess what you're gonna
have the money to go get a tacoma brand
and like like it's going to happen it's
just not happening right now and the
problem is this instant gratification
and you're over compensating right like
you're in a crappy spot right now where
you're living so we need to go get in a
really nice spot with really nice
furniture and all this you got to find a
middle ground brandon so i want you guys
to i mean sell the cars tomorrow i want
you to get a thousand dollars asap and
then i want you to start working on this
credit card debt and pay it off but with
these cars gone it's going to help the
debt amount and i want you guys to save
in three to six months of expenses and
with your your cert you know your your
job everything that you guys are doing
in 24 months brandon your life is going
to look different we're going to give
you a free membership a year membership
to ramsay plus for you and your wife to
work together
on this plan was she unclear no she was
not thank you for that rachel if you are
driving your dream truck and you live
with roaches you are not living the
dream you're living a nightmare dude
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day
comes from luke 6 27-28
love your enemies do good to those who
hate you bless those who curse you
pray for those who mistreat you
martin luther king jr said we must
accept finite disappointment but never
lose infinite hope
good stuff there open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five randall joins us next he's in waco
texas randall welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are you great how can we help
today
so just kind of uh get started on a
brief little thing so i come from a
family of uh
addiction and uh not a very wealthy uh
group of people and uh somehow i was
able to break free from that and i was
in law enforcement for for most of my
adult life
and then me and my wife decided that we
were gonna start a trucking company and
we did she quit her job and
you're gonna
everybody's gonna think we're full for
some of the things that we've done but
she quit her job we pulled her
retirement put it all into this business
so anyways
i drive a lot and so i listened to you
guys a lot just
recently and it wasn't until i started
listening to you guys that i realized i
didn't escape the addiction that my
family had my addiction just spending
money
so
that being said
i've
rared back really hard i have my
thousand dollar savings
um i've got a list of every all my debts
and things
um
i have our houses paid for um
so my most important question the reason
why i'm calling it is because i the
business that we started i had to buy a
new truck and the new truck is like 68
000
and we find out that so the truck
payment is about 1400 a month
that being said the insurance for the
company that i started is also about
1500 a month
so it just feels really heavy on that
side of things because it makes
my business build about forty five
hundred dollars a month plus my home
bills about twenty two hundred dollars a
month
so um
just trying to figure out
um
the right path to go through should i
try to
ditch this vehicle and get something
else but i just really need something
reliable i don't need to be breaking
down
driving 1500 miles
in a week you know
well randall i heard you say these words
that always it always gets me a little
riled up when you said i had to
i had to buy the 70 000 truck to start
my business right
you didn't have to you chose to
yes sir and so the good news is we can
choose to do some other things choose to
make some better decisions and so yes i
would be getting rid of this truck uh
can you find one that's used that you
could pay cash for if you sold it
um
how special is this one
it's not special i mean it's special
because it does the job but it's not
there's no sentimental value
or anything like that i mean there's
another truck that i have my eye on and
it's about twenty thousand dollars i
love that which is
but it's uh
you know i don't have cash to pay twenty
thousand dollars either that would have
to be another financing situation
uh but it's financing twenty thousand
themes
like so how much could you sell this
truck for today is the car worth the
truck today worth the one that you have
um
well
i haven't looked into that yet um could
you get more than 68 for it
i don't think i can get more than 68 but
i could hopefully get
at or around
that number
okay
no i have
um everything's broken down uh so the
truck is 68 um
me and my wife together have about 92
000 in student loans and there's about
ten thousand dollars in
like credit card payments and such
okay
well the way i do this is using the debt
snowball where i list them out from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate and we start attacking
this thing and that means we need to get
this business revenue up or your wife
needs to work a second job i don't know
what that looks like for you guys but
we've got to get this income up because
your payments you can't even breathe
right now
yeah it's pretty tight how much do you
guys make a year randall
um we haven't completed a full year but
um
so the
my wife so whenever we started this like
i said my wife she uh made the decision
that she was gonna stay home because we
i have seven children
but they they range from 21 years old
and
all the way down to one years old
so anyways
yeah how much you make a year how much
is it
okay yeah yeah um so
typically i can bring home probably
a minimum of about 10 000 maybe 15 000 a
month
but that's not all profit so a lot of
that goes into fuel and insurance and
other things that are like other vehicle
maintenance needs yeah okay
well i mean the i don't like this option
but you trading down 68 000 loan for a
20 000 loan feels a lot better to me to
clear some of this debt and give you
some breathing room
right that's what i was kind of feeling
um
you know i listened to you guys a lot i
bought the
book and i was listening to it and
probably one day
and
but i'm really trying to follow
everything i just want to i don't want
to
abandon the business because i'm hoping
that it will do better but
it'll do better when you have more
margin in your life first of all even if
the revenue stayed exactly where it is
today but right now you need every
single paycheck coming in or else you're
screwed so yeah and randall and you're
so i i would look at a couple of things
because what you've just described you
guys have a full life right i mean you
got seven kids
uh you're on the road working um
and so
this
business that you guys have that is
awesome
i mean i really i would really take into
consideration okay what am i actually
right because there's a lot of expenses
here you listed out so what is this what
am i actually bringing home for my
family uh what's my passion in this is
it going to our revenues projected to
make more are we going to be growing
this thing right like i don't want and
i'm not saying it's a dead-end business
by any means but i don't want you in
something that you're going to be losing
money
or it's not going to be growing and
you're in this perpetual state of like
gosh you're just gone all the time and
you end up not enjoying it so so the job
situation the the business i really want
you guys to look at and be serious at
even though you make crazy life
decisions you know you know she came
home you cashed out you cashed out
retirement all of that to start it
um take the emotions out and i really
want you guys to evaluate that business
together and make sure this is the
lifestyle that you guys want as your
family on just the values aspect
and then when it comes to the debt
yeah i mean if there's anything now
seven kids that's a full house so but if
there's anything that she can do even
staying at home to bring in some extra
money or even that 21 year old if they
can help support the family if they're
living there
no so she doesn't live there she started
her own family
yeah and she graduated nursing school
okay yeah she started beginning her own
life yeah yeah so this is you guys you
and this this is y'all's decision you
know for for what you guys have done and
and i hear a resolve though in your
voice randall that i think is great i
mean i think you really are at the end
of your rope meaning like you're willing
to do whatever yeah what we've done is
not worked and so
um right it is going to be this idea
that it's a it's a marathon it's not
going to be a sprint and that's the hard
thing is we are so used to seeing
results
so quickly we want these things to
resolve so quickly and that's one reason
why we do say the debt snowball because
you at least get these quick wins so
even this ten thousand dollar credit
card debt like if it's multiple credit
cards list them out individually right
like you gotta feel some progress yes i
want you guys to be doing that so um
continue on which you you know sell in
the truck like george said but um keep
chipping away and if there's any way to
raise the income um again and i want you
to abandon a business that you guys
started by any means i don't want to be
i don't want to give you that advice
here on one call
on a four-minute radio call but
but is there is there anything you could
be doing to be making more is there
another a job another industry i don't
know just anything to kind of clean up
this mess for the short term i think um
i mean could you work for someone else
right now and make more on your
take-home pay after all of your expenses
are gone
that could be an option to seek
working with somebody or for somebody
else yeah i get creative man i'd get
real creative at this point and see what
are my options and you know what future
maybe we start that business back up but
right now we've got to clean up a big
mess and you've got a lot of people
relying on this you guys can do it
randall y'all can do this yeah you call
us back we can help in any other way
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to rachel cruz my
co-host all the folks in the booth kelly
ben james zach andrew i got them all
there they are in america thank you guys
so much for listening until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you